good morning we'll now start
we're still in the the first test and
we'll now start on section 9 on page 423
so let's start with the first problem
so problem number one
number one
if five t equals 45 five t is equal to
and t k
t k is equal to one
what is k what is k well five t equals
45 this is an easy equation you divide
both sides by five you get t equals nine
and then you have t k equals one we know
what t is equal to t is equal to nine
right so we get nine k
is equal to one divide both sides by
nine you get k is equal to one over nine
that is choice b
that's pretty straightforward
all right
number two
number two i'll switch colors
number two it takes four complete
rotations
of
it takes four it's early in the morning
i can't even read properly it takes four
complete turns of a crank to raise a
window two inches
so
four
turns
raise the window two inches
two inches
at this rate how many turns does it take
to raise the same window
three and a half inches
okay so you know four turns two inches
just to simplify things we can say well
that's the same thing as
well
two
two turns
per inch right
two turns per inch or you could even say
one turn per half inch but let's just
say two turns per inch i just divided
the top by two right if four turns to do
two inches it's going to take two turns
to do one inch and it wants to know the
same window
three and a half inches
three actually when i first read it i
read it as three and a half feet so oh
actually this is this isn't bad three
and a half so we want to go three and a
half
inches it's early in the morning my
brain is still foggy three and a half
inches
so actually i mean we could actually
even ignore this
so we could just set this up as a ratio
four turns
goes goes two inches is equal to
x turns for three and a half and three
and a half you could let's just write
that as
we could write that as three point five
or we could write that as
seven halves
x is to seven halves and then we cross
multiply
so 4 times 7 over 2 is equal to 2x
and then
this cancels with this and we have 14 is
equal to 2x
x is equal to seven
turns
and that's choice b sorry for leading in
the wrong direction i thought they said
three and a half feet at first
okay turn the page
number three
image
clear
all right i'll switch colors again
keeps it interesting for me at least
okay
if x over y is equal to two-thirds so
x
over y
is equal to two-thirds
what is the value of
three
x
over
two y
so we know this how and how do we get
the value of this well we can just
manipulate this relationship
algebraically so we have three x over 2y
on the left hand side and then whenever
we end up on the right hand side is our
answer so let's see how you do that so
we start off with x
over y
is equal to
over 3.
well to get here let's multiply both
sides by three right so if you do a
three
over here
you have to also multiply this side by
three
and then if we multiply both sides by
one half right because this two in the
denominator is essentially one half
right
then you end up with a 2 here
and you end up with a 2 here
so now we have 3x and 2y and now we have
2 times 3 is 6
3 times 2 is 6
and that equals one
choice c
all right the next one looks like i have
to do some drawing so let me clear this
out a little bit
number four
in the figure above let me draw the
figure above looks complicated
okay so i have one line that goes
roughly straight like this
i have one line that goes straight up
like this
another line that crosses that line
something like that
and then i got a bunch of points let me
draw the points it takes more time to
draw these than to maybe do them
although i haven't done this i don't
know
maybe it will take time n
this is
p
t
and then
r
s
and then i have
o
and i got the angle they're calling this
angle y
calling this y degrees
they say this angle here is 20 degrees
and they say this is a right angle
and they say that this angle right here
is x degrees all right so let's read
what they're saying now so in the figure
above
ps so this is ps
and tr intersected o right we drew that
o n is perpendicular to ps right o n is
particular this is my little
perpendicular
signal looks like an r okay that's
what is the value of
y
minus
x
interesting
so y
minus x so let me ask you uh
a question
y is the opposite angle to what right if
you remember from the geometry
opposite angles are equivalent right if
i have two lines that intersect like
this
then this angle is going to be equal to
this angle right
so we know this is y so what angle is
opposite y
well this angle is opposite y
this whole thing
right so what is this angle this angle
is x degrees
plus this 90 degrees right
it's x plus 90. that's this whole angle
right i added this part of it plus this
part that equals this whole angle and
it's the same thing as y and they just
really you know they do all this stuff
to really confuse you wrote 20 degrees
here now none of that i mean
that none of that really matters so
y
is going to be equal to this whole angle
and that whole angle is going to be
equal to this 90 degrees
right is equal to this part
plus this part
plus x
subtract x from both sides you get y
minus x is equal to 90.
that's it that was number four that's
choice c
i do all that and
this problem took too too little time
okay your image
invert
all right
okay so here they got a schedule in the
schedule above and hopefully you have
your book open i'm on page 424 in the
schedule above each session is to be one
and a half hours long each break is to
be quarter hour long and lunch is to be
one hour long all right if session
oh boy i should just draw this thing and
maybe i'll it'll run into the
it'll run into the
oh no no no no i didn't want to do
undo
okay
so this is my
chart
three columns
i've got this one
and i got this one
and then i'm gonna have one two three
four five six seven
okay so then this
two
three
four
i know i'm around space
five
i'm trying to make this too easy
just too neat eight i don't know if i
ran out of space or not but anyway i'll
probably have to continue this in the
next
in the next video but i'll just keep
drawing until the time runs out in the
next video i'll be all set up so see
this is event
event
begin time
begin
end
actually i'll just continue this in the
next video i don't want to waste your
time drawing this i'll draw it and then
we'll start the next video on this
problem see you soon